con el trompillo byd en debatirán frente
a frente por primera vez y las recientes
revelaciones sobre las finanzas de
trauma amenazan con calentar el debate a
favor de los demócratas el new york
times obtuvo las declaraciones de
impuestos del mandatario y divulgó que
no pagó nada durante una década y sólo
aportó 750 dólares en 2016 y lo mismo en
2017 tras llegar a la casa blanca rahm
se limitó a decir que son noticias
falsas aprovechando la situación joe
biden y su fórmula vicepresidencial
kamala harris hicieron públicas sus
declaraciones de impuestos sólo el año
pasado el líder demócrata pagó unos 288
mil dólares la pandemia es otro de los
grandes focos los demócratas han culpado
al presidente por la crisis generada a
raíz del virus
trump siempre abogó por un rápido
levantamiento de las restricciones para
salvar la economía aún cuando la
enfermedad avanzaba con rapidez y hoy
hay más de 7 millones de casos y más de
200.000 muertes el debate también estará
enmarcado por las protestas contra la
discriminación racial y la brutalidad
policial sin embargo el tema ha sido
simplemente nombrado como raza y
violencia en nuestras ciudades lo que se
considera una inclinación a favor de
trump por parte de la
foxx medio cercano a los republicanos
trump ha tratado de persuadir a los
votantes de que elegir a su adversario
sumiría al país en caos mientras que
bardem acusa al presidente de alentar la
violencia y no condenar los ataques de
supremacistas blancos la puja sobre
quién reemplazará a la fallecida jueza
ruth báder ginsburg en la corte suprema
también ha atizado el debate entre ambos
partidos
joe nominó a la conservadora y miconi
baird y los liberales temen sobre un
retroceso en temas como el aborto los
antecedentes políticos de ambos
candidatos también están sobre la mesa
como las acusaciones de corrupción
contra los baiden y de interferencia
rusa a favor de chon para poder llegar a
la casa blanca